[Musique]
vous avez peut-être vu le film s'attirer
qui intitulé don't lookup ou Denis
Cosmic en français ce film raconte
l'histoire de la découverte d'une
immense comète sur le point de percuter
la Terre ce sont deux scientifiques
interprétés par Leonardo DiCaprio et
Jennifer Lawrence qui tire la sonnette
d'alarme
mais petit problème il se bute à
l'indifférence généralisée celle des
médias qui préfèrent traiter de toutes
sortes de modalités celle du
gouvernement en plein déni obsédé par sa
réélection et des intérêts économiques
obnubilé par les profits qu'ils peuvent
soutirer à cette catastrophe annoncée
tout ça au détriment du bien collectif
en gros ce film est un reflet de notre
époque une métaphore inspirée de notre
réaction face à la menace des
changements climatiques mais au-delà de
ça ce film met en relief des billets
cognitifs qui sont ancrés en nous tous
et qui contribue au fonctionnement de
notre cerveau qui doit traiter et trier
chaque jour des tonnes d'informations ce
sont aussi ces fameux biais cognitifs
qui vont en sorte qu'on est tous des
victimes potentielles de la
désinformation alors revenons un peu à
la trame du film beaucoup refusent bref
d'accepter la réalité parce qu'elle est
trop dure et qu'elle les prime dans leur
désirs et leurs besoins les plus
immédiats c'est comme ça que la
désinformation se répand aussi comme une
poudre qui fait en sorte qu'une frange
importante la population ni obstinément
l'existence de la comète c'est ici
qu'entre en scène le biais de
confirmation très connu en psychologie
ce billet fait en sorte content
sélectionner les informations vrai ou
fausse qui renforce nos préconceptions
nos croyances dans le film malgré
l'urgence d'agir pour détruire la comète
des dirigeants et des citoyens se
tournent les pauses ou détourne le
regard mais il y a un billet de notre
cerveau qui fait en sorte qu'on ne passe
pas à l'action ce que les psychologues
nomment la diffusion de la
responsabilité ou encore l'effet
spectateur les expériences en
psychologie donc clairement démontré
plus il y a témoin de la scène moins
chaque personne se sent interpellé on
s'observe l'un l'autre dans l'attentisme
et dans un très très grand groupe
personne n'agit c'est un peu ce qui se
passe avec les changements climatiques
ou avec la comète dans le film en
question et c'est aussi un phénomène qui
à l'oeuvre dans la prolifération de la
désinformation très peu de gens vont
intervenir pour stopper la diffusion
d'une fausse nouvelle ou encore vérifier
la véracité ça demande du temps des
efforts de l'énergie à dernier billet
celui de l'impuissance acquise même
parmi ceux qui sont convaincus des
effets dévastateurs de la comète ou
encore des changements climatiques on
n'agit pas parce qu'on se sent
impuissant malgré tous nos efforts
individuels on a l'impression que c'est
impossible de changer de cours des
choses c'est le destin une sorte de
fatalité on peut faire le parallèle ici
avec la des infos à quoi bon c'est plus
grand que moi mais non mais non tant
pour les changements climatiques que
pour la désinformation la somme des
petits gestes individuels peut changer
le cours des choses des clés pour
déjouer nos biens cognitifs et éviter de
tomber dans le piège à des infos et
passer à l'action c'est de remettre en
question ce qu'on entend ce qu'on voit
aussi chercher les sources qui est le
messager est-ce qu'on se défait des
chiffres validés contre vérifier est-ce
qu'il y a un intérêt dissimulé derrière
tout ça s'informer davantage sur le
sujet aussi un bon conseil en plus de
consulter une variété de source prendre
conscience du rôle aux émotions c'est
archi important le rôle des émotions de
leur impact sur ce qu'on consomme sur ce
qu'on partage en matière d'information
agir là où on peut c'est ça qui fait la
différence
[Applaudissements]